[Music]  we gotta go  i'm gonna have to break a window to get  inside that thing  oh nobody's afraid of heights  [Music]  don't move  [Music]  [Music]  blue had a baby that's impossible  hey girl  you look just like your mother  [Music]  genetic power has now been unleashed  we made a terrible mistake  the doomsday clock might be about out of  time  if our world's going to survive what  matters is what we do now  i can use your expertise  you coming or what  a baby raptor i made a promise we would  bring her home  you made a promise  to a dinosaur yeah  what  [Music]  everybody hold on to somebody  that can't be right  what is that biggest carnivore the world  has ever seen  see not so bad  [Music]  [Music]  you